a large part of that comes from exactly
the things that we've been talking about
which is people have been you know
making job choices early career choices
that are not really well suited for them
and then getting into jobs with the idea
that they'll just do it for a couple of
years make a lot of money pay off their
debt and then find something that they
like but what happens too often is it's
actually really hard to go from making
$200,000 a year to making $100,000 a
year so they don't make the move out
once they've been in it for a couple
years and suddenly they're locked in a
career that isn't really satisfying to
them a big part of that is our fault the
law schools fault because as I say we've
we've always done much too little to
really help them think about their
choices while they're in school and
we've made it easy for them to just
follow this path so you know so we need
to reduce that I think we need to help
people actually while they're in law
school you know find their way to a
career within the law that will be
fulfilling and says it's not the
practice of law as I say the practice of
law is great it's it's fascinating you
get to work with amazing people you get
to do important things you get to help
people in a big way so it's just a
question of helping people find that
part of the legal profession that does
that for them and we haven't done enough
of that and I think too many people have
done too little now there's there's two
other aspects to this the one is for
what it's worth I think the reports are
somewhat exaggerated we've been doing
our own research on this and and
actually there's a study that's just
come out called after the JD and after
the JD - and the levels of satisfaction
among legal professionals are much
higher than a lot of the other studies
are anecdotal reports would have you
think they're still not as high as they
ought to be but it's I think not quite
as bad as conventional wisdom now holds
and then the second thing is you know
there's also a large amount of evidence
that suggests that if you can find a way
to make public service a part of your
career you'll have a much better career
and so this is something else that I
think the law schools have to take on
we've taken this on as one of the
central tenets that we try and give
students in their three years there
which is some exposure while they're in
school - to some form of public service
whether it's you know
a pro bono practice full-time work
government work whatever it is you know
we say to them you come to law school
you're going to get a license to
practice law it's a really powerful
thing in this society you can do a lot
of a lot of things with it now you're
going to make a choice what kind of
career you want to have and and we don't
have you know it's not our judgement
about that you should make your own
choice there are a lot of different
careers in law you have to find
something that seems to suit you but
whatever practice you choose whatever
kind of law you choose to go into
there's room in it do public service and
that will be both good for the community
but we'll also you'll be much more
fulfilled in your career if you do it
and so we try and model for them the
different ways to do it we turn to a lot
to help students find their way into
that even the ones who are not going to
you know become full-time Public
Interest lawyers it doesn't matter
right there's still ways to do this and
and and we'll try and help you and that
will increase career satisfaction as
well